[Müzik]
tüm zamanların en çok merak edilen
sorusuyla başlamak istiyorum Piramitler
nasıl inşa edildi
4500 yıl önce inşa edilen Bu yapıların
nasıl yapıldığı birçok tartışmaya sebep
olurken akıl almaz bir matematik
kullanıldığı Şüphesiz ortada
Mısır Piramitleri adına yapılan kişinin
doğum gününde ve tahta çıktığı tarihte
yılda iki kere Güneş alacak şekilde inşa
edilmiştir ve o koca blokların Yani 20
ile 80 ton arasındaki blokların
metrelerce yükseğe taşınması büyük bir
matematik gerektirir
Demek ki binlerce yıllık tarihi olan bu
piramitler matematik sayesinde ayakta
kalmayı başardılar Peki bize ayakta
tutacak matematik ne
sorunun cevabını Kemal Sunal'ın bir
filminden örnekle başlayalım
Kemal Sunal Sakar Şakir filminde bir
Veresiye defteri satıyor kiloyla satıyor
Ama içinde 50.000 liralık borç olan
defteri 50 TL'ye vermiş oluyor
mahallede seviniyor buna ama kendinizi
bir de market sahibinin yerine koyun
market sahibi yerinde olsanız Tahmin
edebiliyorum ki ufak bir hüzün içinde
olacaksınız
günümüzde hala verilsin Defteri
mantığında yani tek merkezde toplanan
birçok sistem var Bu sistemler bizim
güvenliğimizi güvenirliğimizi ve
sürdürebilirliğimizi bozmakta
Peki şimdi gelin Sizinle bir örnek
yapalım Ben market sahibi olayım siz de
Mahalleli ben size birçok defter
dağıtıyorum ve bu defterlerde benim
defterimle bağlı Yani hepimizin defteri
birbirine bir a ile bağlı bu defterlere
ben ne yazarsam kendi defterime ne
yazarsam sizin defterlerinizde de aynısı
yazıyor Ve bu salonunun yarısını defteri
yandı diyelim geriye ne kaldı diğer
yarısı ve benim defterim yani %50'den
fazla iz değil mi Bu ne demek biliyor
musunuz
yalan defterlerin yerini geriye kalan
defterler ve benim defterimle çok kolay
doldurabiliriz
blockchain teknolojisi işte bunu
sağlıyor bizi kurtaracak matematik İşte
bu
piramitleri yapacak matematik unutulduğu
Evet ama bizim unutulacak artık hiçbir
şeyimiz yok çünkü silinemeyen bir
sistemle karşı karşıyayız unutmak
demişken biz sadece matematiğimizi
unuttuk sizce
matematiğimiz eksik olsa da güveniniz
Tam da Birbirimize aslında Sadece Güven
eksikliğimizi tamamlamak için
çırpınıyoruz bu güven eksikliğimizi
icatlar
dahilinde tamamlamaya çalışıp bir
şeylerle o güveni yerine koymaya
çalışıyoruz icatlar ihtiyaçtan doğar
kelimesi
Aslında hüzünlü bir hal almış olsa da
bizim için geleceğin kapılarını
araladığı için küçük bir tebessüm
ettiriyor işte bize bu duyguları yaşatan
şeyin adı yani matematiği yeni hali blok
çayı birbirine bağlı bloklardan oluşan
bu sistem 2009'dan bu yana hiç hata
vermeden çalışmaktadır Ama öyle böyle
bir çalışma değil 7-24 çalışmakta ve tek
bile dememiştir
kırılması için yani birbirine bağlı
bloklar var ve bunların kırılması içinse
bir sistem daha geliştirilemedi Siz
kırmak ister misiniz Ben size biraz
ipucu vereyim isterseniz siz kırıp
kırmayacağınıza kendiniz karar verin
10 dakika içerisinde dünyadaki bütün
zincirleri erişip tüm zincirlerin
şifresini kırıp ve %50 birlik bir
kısmının bloğunu değiştirmeniz gerekiyor
ki bu sistem karışsın yani hesabınıza 10
milyon TL geçirebilirsiniz bu şekilde
ancak tüm dünyadaki herkesin
bilgisayarını 10 dakika içinde
kırabiliyorsanız zaten 10 milyon TL'ye
de ihtiyacınız yok demektir
var mı denemek isteyen Peki bunu
kendinden önceki ve sonraki bloğun
adresini tutan bu veri dolu kutucuklar
aynı zamanda şifrede olup herkesin
gizliliğini de korumaktadır yani
Ahmet'ten Ayşe'ye bir para gidiyor ama
sadece bunun datasını görebiliyorsunuz
içindeki miktarı Ahmet ve Ayşe'de olan
anahtarla anahtar ile sadece Ahmet ve
Ayşe görebiliyor blockchain ile
hayatımızda böyle değişiklikler olurken
başta neler değişti gelin bir de bunlara
bakalım İşin aslı güvenden uzaklaşmış
Bir toplumun yerini matematiğe olan
güven ile telafi ederek şeffaflık
kazanmış Ayrıca geleneksel işlemleri de
hızlandırmış olduk hızlanan Bu
geleneksel işlemleri bir bakalım
yurtdışı firmalarının birinden bir talep
var 10.000 ton Çelik isteniyor Bizim de
demir çelik fabrikamız var Biz de bu
ihtiyacı karşılamak istiyoruz Tabii ki
şimdi akıllarıyla gelen ilk soru ya ben
ürünü gönderdiğimde paramı alamazsam ben
paramı alamazsam büyük ihtimalle batmış
olurum çünkü Buradan yurt dışına giden
10 bin ton bir demiri var para büyük
olunca bu soruyu sormamızda gayet normal
tabi Sadece bu sorunun sürekli Kafamızda
dolanmaması için aracı kurumları devreye
sokarız ilk akla gelen aracı kurum banka
var bankalar bize Güven sağlamak için
belirli bir miktar yüzde alarak iki
şirket arasında ki anlaşmayı sağlıyor
nedir Bu anlaşma belli evraklar belli
işlemler doğrultusunda bize
ürünümüzün güvenle gidip paramızın
güvenliğine gelmesini sağlıyor
Biz demiri gönderiyoruz Demir karşı
tarafa ulaşınca paramızda banka
havuzundan bize aktarılıyor Tabii ki bu
kadar basit değil bu işlemler bir karış
evrak 10-15 gün evrak onaylanması 40 ile
60 gün ise Bu ürünün oraya gitmesiyle
iki aya aşkın bir süreyi alıyor Bu iki
aylık süren süreci Hadi gelin Bir de
bizim yeni matematiğimizde inceleyelim
bu matematikte şöyle oluyor ben
satıcıyım karşı tarafa alıcı ülkelerin
hiçbir önemi yok ve biz ticaret yapmak
istiyoruz araya sadece bir akıllı
sözleşme iliştirerek ve bunu blok
zinciri ekleyerek tüm dünyanın
bilgisayarlarına gönderiyoruz herhangi
bir hata durumunda Ben malı
göndermediğim durumda bütün dünya o
adamın arkasında olacak veya ben paramı
alamadığımda Bütün dünya benim arkamda
olacak
yeterince zaman ve para kaybettiğimiz bu
sistem
bizim yalan veresiye defterleri gibi bir
bloğunu kaybetse Yani bir defterini
kaybetse bir evranımızı kaybetsek bütün
sistem çöp olacak ve 2 aylık emeğimize
çok çöpe gidecekti Ama şimdi yeni
sisteminizde artık 24 saat içerisinde bu
ticareti gerçekleştirmiş oluyoruz İşte
bu kadar basit
bu kadar şifrelemeden bahsettik Madem
biraz da Detaylara inelim
kriptografi blockchain'in temeli
diyebiliriz Aslında bu sistem şifresiz
olsa da hiçbir anlamı şifreli bir
şifresiz olsa hiçbir anlamı olmayacaktı
kriptografi okunabilir verileri
istenmeyen kişilerin anlamasını
engellemek için oluşturulmuş bir
şifreleme yöntemi bunu ilk kullanansa
Sezar bildiğiniz romanın Romalı jül
Sezar bu sistemi kullanan ilk kişiydi ve
Sezer algoritması Sezer şifrelemesi diye
bir sistemi Ben hala yazılımlarında
kullanıyorum bu sistem şu şekilde size
Sizin elinize bir mektup var ve çok
karışık harflerden oluşuyor ve Mektubun
sağ üst köşesinde bir sayı var Bu sayı
diyelim ki 3
3 sayısı ve karışık harflerden oluşan bu
mektubu çözmek için sadece Düşünmeniz
gerekiyor oradaki Örneğin a harfi olsun
a harfi şifreli bir karakter 3D bizim
anahtarımız bu A harfinin üstüne o 3
haneli karakteri ekleyerek asıl mektuba
ulaşmış oluyoruz yani A'dan 3 gidiyoruz
bcd Denizli'nin d'si bizim mektuptaki
asıl karakterimiz bütün mektup bu
şekilde çözüldükten Sonra işte anlamlı
mektuba ulaşıp sorunlarımızı
çözebiliyoruz ve savaşlarda birbirimize
mektup gönderebiliyoruz ve kimse de
okumamış oluyor işte kriptografi işte
matematik
geçen haftalarda da İlber Ortaylı'nın
bir konuşmasına katılmıştım orada çok
dikkatimi çeken bir cümle kurdu
geleneksiz gelecek olmaz düşündüm acaba
olabilir mi diye Ama sanırım geleneksiz
bir gelecek olsa da geleneklerimizi bize
hatırlatacak bir matematik var bu
matematiğin adı blockchain teşekkürler
[Müzik]